كانت لاكيا بيلي تبلغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات عندما
تم تشخيصها بمرض فقر الدم المنجلي ،
كنت أستيقظ من نوم عميق في
ألم شديد بحاجة للذهاب إلى
المستشفى
، وقد تحملت مئات
الإجراءات الجراحية والاستشفاء
الذي يطلق عليه اسم الخلية المنجلية بسبب
طريقة الخلايا.
تتشكل مثل منجل لا
تحصل أنسجتك على كمية الأكسجين التي تحتاجها
مما قد يؤدي إلى تلف الأعضاء
ويمكن أن يتسبب في موت
لاكيا تفوقت في المدرسة على الرغم من فقدان
أسابيع من الفصول
التي علمتني والدتي أنني سأحتاج إلى
تحسينها ثلاث مرات  لكي أعتبر
نصف ما تعلمه جيدًا ،
فأنا شخص الطالب الذي يذاكر كثيرا ، حصلت في
النهاية على درجة الدكتوراه في
طب
أمراض
الدم الجزيئي والطب التجديدي.
زرع هو العلاج الوحيد المعروف الذي ترأسه أيضًا
اتحاد الخلايا المنجلية
غير الهادفة للربح التي شاركت في تأسيسها ، وهدفنا الرئيسي
هو ضمان وجود  مساحة
لمرضى الخلايا المنجلية ومقدمي الرعاية
ليكونوا في مركز
التوعية والسياسات المتعلقة بالتشريعات البحثية ، وهي
مستشارة حكومية وتعمل مع شركات الأدوية
في العلاج الجيني ، ونحن نعمل بجد
للتأكد من أن الأجيال القادمة
لا تضطر إلى التعايش معها  هذا المرض